that you know
you're gonna have to get
[Music]
wet just getting stuff up here
okay is you right here what to do with
the jacket
yeah i'm uh this one right here
yeah okay we'll be doing just ammo
[Music]
tell me when you're finished
oh so how are you going to make sure the
other side of the door you hear
rough voices and laughter and rocket
fire
yeah we gonna open it right spoke about
[Music]
you know what's crazy this game wouldn't
have had any
voice dialogue
that's what i heard damn it looks like
we killed them all
yes the fun's over that's actually
really important if you think about it
oh wait a minute maybe not
howdy hot lander
oh as much fun as it is killing fight
longness
you get to pick this i like it best when
the dale use your blood
happens in person oh it says
yeah you're right the rest is gonna be
sorry he stayed home
he loves him some entrails
say who the hell
are the harbingers of the deluge the
[ __ ] end of the old world
and the beginning of the new and it all
begins
here you little prayer dog what i
do to you the dorsey's gonna do to all
the color i know
so squeal all you want no one's coming
to save
oh he got he got his head
remember remember your captain from the
beginning he doesn't kill
jared the one that still activated that
truck
yeah yeah she's still alive shut up
heads up rangers
more incoming
i don't know how to move anything okay
ap
this is too much ap oh it's like
external
put the pluto
[Music]
i'm gonna go behind hold on people 67
[Music]
right here i will go up like behind that
box behind you
[Music]
this one right here i can't see where
your
marker is oh i thought you could see my
marker
you talk about the box behind me yeah
okay
[Music]
okay now they got like a overwatch or
attack move i see why attackers
i ain't got enough things yeah
okay so i got two so that joint in the
middle is the action points in the
bottom middle
yeah okay this is abilities items
okay attack oh so i can't really is
there like a
a defense where it's like crouch you
know how like xbox got the defensive
mode
no i don't think that i got it i got an
[Music]
internet
[Applause]
[Music]
should let us see what you picking
though
[Music]
um she getting helped up though
and it takes so much action points to
restoration i don't know if i could
shoot from back here i attack ball
i can shoot that tank how do you switch
targets from what you want to shoot i
think it's right here
[Music]
okay yeah my man is too you got me back
here
[Music]
yeah i'm going to get in the mix because
i can't see that now
i missed all my ap i can't
shoot not enough
of these items i got six what's this
stand up cannot change dance recover
stand up to your first one again
[Music]
yeah that's what oh okay yep all right
so i can't do that
so what's this final actions tap what's
that
click that
oh there we go defend yeah they gotta
defend for only one ap
hunker down that's what i'm talking
about we need that hunker down
usable prepare or end your turn all
aimed your turn and carry up to two
unused ap that's good
i'm gonna use that because i got two ap
i'm gonna compare
i got it what they need to work on
though is they need to let me see
your thing so i can know what you get
yeah but i think that that
that's definitely gone at this point
they probably just got lucky to get this
out at that point
[Music]
what is dope two players at least i like
the concept
[Music]
i'm staying here yeah
[Music]
all right so now i got to prepare now
[Music]
he on high ground
[Music]
neither get closer which i wouldn't
suggest that i would just shoot because
you'll break through that cover
oh okay i can bust through they got
destructive recovery yeah
all right i'm gonna try it all right so
exactly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
help
nice
[Music]
isn't there a box to the bottom right
where you are
like the item you could pick up on the
map
no yeah there is it's but i i ain't
trying to move they'll kill me no don't
do it now but i just i just want to make
sure that we'll just get it after we
beat them
all right and i got it
[Music]
[Music]
ability that's lit up oh yeah yeah shoot
that
shoot that shoot that let's go shoot
that
torrent strike all right hold on
come on there we go all right
oh that's crazy that's like my super
bowl
[Music]
all right so i still got three um what
i'm gonna do
probably just carry two over to the next
round
let me next time i want to practice
overwatch i still
have not been able to practice over what
[Music]
yep i'm prepared you go
i was kind of impressed with my my 20
yeah how did i
was kind of impressed by 21
that was at 95.
[Music]
i'm kind of impressed my man had 21
seconds
oh sure they got that oh tactics
oh my thing killed those two dudes yeah
you murdered
[Music]
[Music]
okay all right if we kill them do we
lose the ability if we kill all of do we
lose the ability to lose items on the
battlefield no as long as they're
like something doesn't happen forcing us
to leave this
area we can still live right okay
so what i'm gonna do and the good thing
is when you lose one person
[Music]
all right you go my food is there i put
[Music]
myself
how do you keep missing can you not be
any less pathetic
[Music]
your man mess again
[Music]
oh
[Music]
rocket straight up your ass it's not
designed to be missing
[Music]
what that that dude there got a rocket
[Music]
the one that's right in front of me the
yeah the one that no the one that uh
is back with her if you zoom in you'll
see he's got a rocket launcher
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he creeping
he creeping
yeah i'm a bust you're going to kill the
dude right next to you though
yeah yeah you should have a good shot a
chance
but you shoot it like you have a 49
chance i miss a bullet you shoot like
50. so
all right cool cool so i got this
ability
i'm gonna go i'm gonna defend with this
one point
i'm gonna try to take out that sniper
yeah
watch him
[Music]
[Music]
please kill him this home girl up here
kill him
oh you have to rock it at me good thing
i put defend on
oh that's great oh she got it
the good thing about it is come over
here and loop right here click the
salute
and look what happens when you click
okay muscle tissue
like you don't want to loot individually
oh you have to go to each box
so i'm gonna do all okay nice
hold on hold on back at it okay before
we do that before we move forward you
know me i got to be in my items i wanted
to see
my joint though after we get this part
major friends breath steams are her
clenched teeth her guts are spilling
through her bloody fingers
first lady's clear she's in shock it's
incredible she's still calm nice work
finishing off that
jerks crew she saved us did you find any
other services
okay what happened to you
oh this is other players i got jumped by
more of these [ __ ] as i was
sneaking up here i got them all but the
last one got me with a
skinny knife before i finished him
that was a good kid thank you
you did well
now
we do that and the patriarch sends aid
to the arizona rangers
and the rangers are [ __ ] up
pretty much we're doing something
because we need allies
so we're hoping this to solve his
situation
when we first heard from the patriarch
general woodson sentence
sent an advanced team to colorado led by
angela
but they went dark we have to find them
who was angela no she found her way home
and found out all her squadmates had
died fighting a courtesies
probably why she volunteered for the
advanced team mission
catch my breath and we can go
so you want to kill her all right so it
says how are you doing
damn wait hold on get down you need to
chill
nah we ain't doing that i'm just
checking out why are you going smoker
no i'm not i'm i haven't clicked nothing
yeah because that's what hard ass does
right no this is hard as
euthanizer is like we killing her what
without
i mean she's dead i'ma just be real with
you i don't think that's really yeah but
i don't see
any all i see is you you got another
option that says
look i don't see that option on my
screen yeah kill her put her out of her
misery is what i got
roll all the way down let me see that
because i can't see that
oh man i gotta scroll down oh yeah i got
it
now you cannot oh no no no he said you
basically you want to try to help her
out
achievement on here
all right so i got new skills it looks
like
i got a mask let's make my first day
okay
big guns i have a machine gun better go
hit chance okay hard ass and timing
others to do stuff
nerd stuff allows you to use that yeah
let's do that
all right
[Applause]
am i gonna get eventually get explosives
yeah you get like rocket launchers and
stuff like that
sneaky [ __ ] makes it easier to just film
alarms invade detection spot here oh i
like that yeah
i like let me put up the sneakiest
wow how often lockpicking come in we
have a rocket launcher with us
okay weird science increased damage you
deal with unconventional weapons that
survival and pressure building dangers
on the world map
it's mad skills you can put your
leadership
information i told you this company
don't get enough respect
like this is rpg mechanics
not mass effect one like all that
garbage everybody
how do you heal another squad though i
didn't see a way i could have healed you
during the battle
you have to use a an ability got you
all right so give me a second
[Music]
this thing looks very compensation okay
so now
confirm changes all right
get confirmed
how do you all right
even this screen was confirmed any yes
right besides that
when do i when do i get these attributes
to go up
you just have to level up i got
mad stuff in my inventory
i think you're trying to matter okay
so how do i know what i have one
versus okay
all right [ __ ] quit like there's no way
to come
oh there are you big guns okay
i believe so yes or explosives which one
are you big guns or explosives
uh i think i'm big hugs i check i think
i am yeah i'm big guns
so we we have we have a couple big guns
with us we have flame
uh sprayer we have roasty uh roasty
toasty
thrower uh
i'm like specialized can i sort it we
have a wardrobe
mj7 that's a message
all right but with um big guns what so
wait how do i can i sort it so i can see
there's so many items on the screen i'm
just trying to sort
it go home i'm a weapon okay there we go
okay so i see the grizzly so roasty
toasty
that's considered a big oh yeah i would
that's explosive though i i can't i
don't i'm not explosive oh okay
toasty toast
see i'm gonna do the flank though now
that i can't hit from farther right
flamethrower you can't hear
all right you have two weapons oh okay
so i'm gonna put
secondary but okay
if i remember it like if you go back to
the main thing you push the right and
left on the kneepad it'll switch back
and forth between your
weapons but i think in battlefield cost
it costs ap to switch them
i shoot all right so now actually i got
a heavy machine gun
and i got the big gun joint so you think
that's a good
flow or should i switch it out well
right now
you can really keep none of this [ __ ]
you have like we're gonna find other
stuff
okay give me one second before we start
cuz i just gotta
oh